TAKE.
WE WILL GET TO THE SIDE SHOW
IN JUST A MINUTE.
FIRST UP THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY STILL HAS NOT DECIDED
WHO IS GOING TO CHALLENGE
DONALD TRUMP IN NEXT FALL'S
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE FIELD OF 2020 CANDIDATES
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST IN
HISTORY.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY SEEMS
TO BE RUNNING FROM THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO SOME GUY
WHO IS LITERALLY THE MAYOR
OF SOUTH BEND.
IN CASE YOU ARE WONDERING IS
THE FOURTH BIGGEST CITY IN
INDIANA.
SMALLER THAN EVANSVILLE
SLIGHTLY LARGER THAN CARAMEL
THAT GUY IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE ARE AN AWFUL LOT
OF PEOPLE RUNNING IN THIS
RACE.
RANGE STRIKINGLY NARROW.
EVERYONE IS PRETTY MUCH
SUPPOSED TO HAVE THE SAME
VIEWS ON EVERYTHING.
ANYBODY TO DISSENTS A LITTLE
BIT IS DENOUNCED AS IMMORAL
OR RACIST OR AGENT OF
RUSSIA.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY RACE IS
VERY MUCH LIKE EVERYTHING
ELSE THE LEFT TOUCHES.
IT'S STRIDENT.
IT'S INTOLERANT ALMOST
UNBELIEVABLY DUMB.
CONGRESSWOMAN TULSI GABBARD
OF HAWAII ONE OF THE VERY
FEW WILLING TO CHALLENGE THE
STATUS QUO.
SHE IS NO CONSERVATIVE SHE
IS A LIBERAL.
SHE CRITICIZES HER PARTY FOR
BECOMING PRO-WAR AND
PRO-CORPORATE MONDAY
PRO-CORPORATE MONOPY
PRO-CORPORATE MONOPOLY.
SHE DID IT AGAIN LAST NIGHT.
WATCH.
>> OUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
UNFORTUNATELY, IS NOT THE
PARTY THAT IS OF, BY AND FOR
THE PEOPLE IT IS A PARTY
THAT HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES
TO BE INFLUENCED BY THE
FOREIGN POLICY ESTABLISHMENT
IN WASHINGTON REPRESENTED BY
HILLARY CLINTON AND OTHERS'
FOREIGN POLICY, BY THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
AND OTHER GREEDY CORPORATE
INTERESTS.
>> Tucker: OH.
SPOKEN BIKE AN OLD FASHIONED
LIBERAL.
THERE IS ONE LEFT.
BUT THINGS ARE CHANGED IN
THE REST OF THE PARTY.
TALK LIKE THIS IS A THREAT
TO THE PRIVATE EQUITY
COMMUNITY NOW THE CORE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO THEIR CHIEF TODAYY KAMALA
HARRIS MOHAMMEDAL
IMMEDIATELY LEAPT FORTH TO
SHUT IT DOWN.
>> I THINK THAT IT IS
COMFORT THAT WE
UNMFORT THAT WE
UNFOORT THAT WE
UNFORTT THAT WE
UNFORTUNTHAT WE
UNFORTUNATAT WE
UNFORTUNATET WE
UNFORTUNATE OWE
UNFORTUNATE ONE
UNFORTUNATE ON THE STAGE
ATTEMPTING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SPENT
FOUR YEARS FULL TIME ON FOX
NEWS CRITICIZING PRESIDENT
OBAMA:  SPENT FULL TIME
CRITICIZING PEOPLE ON THIS
STAGE AS AFFILIATED WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Tucker: YOU OFTEN HEAR
DEMOCRATS CLAIM DONALD TRUMP
DIVIDES AMERICA.
OKAY.
WELL THEY WANT WANT TO UNITE
IT ONE WAY UNITE THE COUNTRY
SPEAK TO EVERYONE WHO LIVES
IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S LITERALLY NOT
ALLOWED.
THE LEFT BELIEVES IT'S WRONG
TO TALK TO PEOPLE YOU
DISAGREE WITH.
WHICH IS WHY THEY BOYCOTT
THIS CHANNEL AND THIS SHOW.
OVER THE NEXT HOUR WE WILL
HAVE MORE CLIPS FROM LAST
NIGHT'S DEBATE WE CAN TELL
YOU NOW THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS WERE NEVER MENTIONED.
ONE WORD FOR EXAMPLE NOBODY
MENTIONED LAST NIGHT WAS
SUICIDE.
SUICIDE WAS RISEN BY MORE
THAN A THIRD SINCE 1999.
LIFE EXPECTANCY WASN'T
MENTIONED EITHER.
DROPPING THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
ILLEGAL DRUGS ONLY MENTIONED
WHEN THEY TOLD US THE WAR ON
DRUGS IS RACIST AND
MARIJUANA NEEDS TO BE
LEGALIZED.
REST OF IT IGNORED.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COMPANIES
WERE ATTACKED BUT ONLY
CHARGING TOO MUCH FOR THEIR
PRODUCTS NOT FOR GETTING
AMERICANS HOOKED ON OPIOIDS,
THE DRUGS THAT HAVE FUELED
THE WAIVE OF DEADLIEST
OVERDOSE.
70,000.
NOT MENTIONED.
DEMOCRATS DID TALK ABOUT
INEQUALITY.
EVERYTHING FOR THEM IS IN
RACIAL TERMS.
OF COURSE.
SOME GROUPS ARE WELL OFF
BECAUSE OF THEIR SKIN COLOR
THEY TOLD US WHILE OTHERS
ARE NOT.
THEY ARE OPPRESSED.
AMERICA IS A RACIST COUNTRY
THEY ARGUED AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
THE TRUTH, IF YOU LIVE HERE,
IS THAT OPPORTUNITY IN
AMERICA IS VANISHING FOR
ALMOST EVERYONE OF ALL
COLORS.
IN 1970, FOR EXAMPLE, 9% OF
30-YEAR-OLDS MADE MORE MONEY
THAN THEIR PARENTS HAD AT
THAT AGE.
IN 2014, ONLY HALF DID.
THOSE ARE ACTUAL NUMBERS.
THAT TELL YOU A LOT.
THEY ARE NOT RACE-BASED
NUMBERS.
THEY ARE NUMBERS THAT TELL
YOU THAT THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS IN PERIL.
ADD TO THAT FAR HIGHER DEBT
LEVELS AND MOST YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THE END ARE ECONOMICALLY
WORSE OFF THAN THEIR PARENTS
WERE AT THE EXACT SAME AGE.
SO, OPPORTUNITY IS IN
DECLINE.
AND THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
FOR IT.
ONE IS THIS.
BIG BUSINESS SUPPORT OPEN
BORDERS FOR THE REST OF THE
WORLD IN ORDER TO KEEP WAGES
DOWN.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WE CAN'T EVEN GUESS TO
WITHIN THE NEAREST MILLION.
THE BEST GUEST AS OF RIGHT
NOW IS ABOUT 22 MILLION
PEOPLE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE
ARRIVE EVERY MONTH.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS.
LAST NIGHT THEY NEVER
MENTIONED FIXING IT.
IN FACT THEY PLEDGED TO TEAR
DOWN BORDER WALLS WE ALREADY
HAVE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
INSTEAD OF HELPING YOUNG
AMERICANS TO HAVE THE
FAMILIES THEY SAY THEY WANT
AND YOUNG PEOPLE SAY THEY
WANT TO HAVE FAMILIES BUT
CAN'T AFFORD IT, NO DEMOCRAT
ADDRESSED THAT INSTEAD
ELIZABETH WARREN TALKED
ABOUT EXPANDING ABORTION AS
A QUOTE ECONOMIC RIGHT.
AND THAT REALLY DOES HE SORT
OF OF SUMS UP PERFECTLY THE